it's great to welcome to the program
today Robert Hockett who is a professor
of law and finance at Cornell University
he is an advisor to congresswoman
Alexandria Castillo Cortez also one of
the architects of the green New Deal and
so the timing of our interview is
actually very good in a sense because
yesterday the Senate voted on taking up
the green New Deal and of course we know
that many Democrats in the Senate
support a lot of the ideas that are in
the plan but there was the perception of
probably accurately that Republicans are
sort of trying to score political points
by forcing a vote on a proposal that is
still more of an overview an
aspirational document so what's your
reaction to so many Democrats voting
present yesterday yeah this is actually
quite familiar David Mitch McConnell
does this a lot he did it this time last
year in connection with another
initiative that the Democrats have been
behind what he essentially does is as a
kind of stunt he'll bring something up
to a vote up for a vote even though
there's been absolutely no discussion of
it yet within the chamber or any either
of the chambers of Congress for that
matter
there have been no committee hearings
there's been no sort of process just
sort of out of the blue all right he
just sort of calls it up for a vote
apparently the hope is that you know if
he catches everybody by surprise like
this they won't vote for it they'll vote
against or some will for and some
against and then it'll lose and then
you'll be able to say oh it lost but the
Democrats are on to this particular
tactic of his and they have been for a
long time so what they do every time
that he announces an intention to pull
this particular stunt again is they all
agree actually just to vote present but
not to vote yay or nay in order to sort
of signal to the walk broader public
that this isn't a real vote and it
wasn't ever meant to be a real vote so
they've effectively just called his
bluff again this time like last time the
people over at Fox News and other
right-wing media they're well aware of
this they've seen this happen a million
times before but then they try to use
the present vote as if it were a no vote
or as though it signaled some sort of
disarray or disagreement within the
ranks
about the merits of the renew deal in
this case or medicare-for-all last year
or other initiatives before that nobody
who actually knows about legislative
process ever falls for that it's just a
line yeah unfortunately a lot of people
don't know about legislative process and
so it's still it's still sort of
effective headlines of Democrats vote
against their own green you deal when as
you mentioned voting president is not
voting for or against but in a sense you
know the sort of cynicism that we have
about this and the predictability that
they would do this it still works
and it still works for a significant
portion of the sort of media consumer
base so I what's next in other words
what's the next step with this green New
Deal
yeah well so as you suggested at the
outset what we have at the moment is a
resolution the resolution is best
thought of as a kind of opening gavel
it's meant to sort of open the national
conversation or a national discussion
about how best to address the now
existentially threatening climate crisis
on the one hand and the sort of profound
economy threatening infrastructural
degradation and manufacturing
degradation of the country on the other
hand we chose the name New Deal sort of
or the component of the green New Deal
name that is the New Deal component
quite deliberately the original New Deal
which a lot of people either
are too young to remember because they
weren't around or just never read the
history of was itself never one
enactment it was never one particular
legislative action or statute a
resolution or what have you it was an
organic process that unfolded over the
course of a decade or more it was
basically constituted by a sequence of
distinct statutory measures each one
building upon its predecessors and each
one passed only after lively national
discussion at the national level at the
state level at the local levels even at
the neighborhood levels at every step
along the way so what that means at
present is that the resolution that was
introduced by congresswoman Acacio
Cortes on the one hand and Senator
Markey on the other at the very
beginning of February was simply the
initiation of that same process
this time around that then takes us to
your more immediate question which is
okay well what comes next probably what
will happen next is that somebody either
the congresswoman or the congresswoman
acting with some of her colleagues or
senator Markey or senator Markey acting
with colleagues in the Senate or some
group of senators and and House members
alike will try to figure out what single
discrete enactment should be the first
enactment to be made what they'll
probably do is focus on something that
Democrats and Republicans alike can get
behind given that you know we don't have
majorities in both houses of Congress
and the White House yet that seems
especially important although to be
quite frank we would like to do all of
this in a bipartisan way even once we
have massive majorities in both houses
and even when we have the White House
again so what does that mean I suspect
again infrastructure or manufacturing
will probably be at the core of the
first one or two enactments we'll
probably try to do it we'll probably try
to replicate yet another feature of the
region of the original New Deal of doing
this and that is to see to it that
whatever projects are undertaken are
meant to be undertaken in literally
every congressional district of the
country so that literally everybody
benefits that was another sort of
marvelous feature of the original New
Deal that people either have forgotten
or never knew one reason that the New
Deal was so popular even among
Republicans was precisely because the
New Deal had projects in literally every
congressional district of the country
meaning that literally everybody would
benefit and that's not just of course
politically savvy which it is but it's
much more than that we think it's just
democracy right or it's justice if the
green New Deal is meant to be for
everybody well then of course it makes
sense for its projects as a total
portfolio to operate to the benefit or
for the benefit of everybody and Robert
one of the criticisms of the bill or the
proposal the initial proposal that I
think are more interesting more worthy
of discussion than the sort of
cartoonish ones that that we sort of I
don't think really need to delve into it
in detail is
that some of the particular timelines
that were generally outlined in the
original 14 page resolution were
unrealistically optimistic so I guess my
question for you is is a two-part
question
one do you agree with that assessment
but more importantly does that matter if
this is just creating sort of an initial
framework for what the end goals are so
I think it's actually false I think
everything about the resolution
everything that's in the resolution is
actually quite feasible and quite doable
I also do take your point that in a
certain sense it doesn't matter because
really the idea here is if you you know
swing for the fences as they say if you
try to hit it out of the park you're all
the more like hit a home run even if it
doesn't go all the way out of the park
right even if it only reaches the stands
or only reaches you know the far wall or
something you're much more likely to
reach that far wall if indeed you are
swinging for the proverbial fences so in
that sense it wouldn't matter if they
were you know completely feasible goals
but that being said right it wouldn't be
plausible to suggest that we do
something that's completely on its face
unrealistic even as a way of getting
people to sort of aspire for more and to
sort of swing for the fences and thereby
not quite make it to the fences you know
you need there needs to be some degree
of feasibility or at least some
plausibility to the stated end goal in
order for people even to bother to try
to get to it in a manner that then might
fall slightly short or might fall far
short
so maybe needless to say then you know
given that we actually do think the
particulars are quite feasible this is
America after all and we are a can-do
country at least that used to be a big
part of our culture that used to be
probably maybe one of the two or three
most fundamental constant sort of
constitutive elements of our culture is
we were a can-do people you know you and
I are perhaps old enough to remember the
old phrase American know-how you don't
hear people dropping that phrase or
using those words as often as you and I
probably did when we were kids but it's
still a thing right the idea of American
know-how and the idea of America as a
can-do country and it's worth noting
that there's not a single extraordinary
thing that this
country has done in its well over two
hundred year history now that wasn't
deemed or sort of denounced as
implausible or crazy when first
propounded right that's very but let me
just give a couple specifics I mean and
again to be clear these are not things
that I think are bad ideas but when for
example we look at ten years to go to
Net Zero greenhouse gas emissions and
upgrade all existing federal buildings I
of course agree with doing that I just
don't see any way that that happens in
ten years even if we start today yeah I
well I guess I don't I don't see why it
couldn't happen you know what I mean we
could if we mobilize the resources and
we've mobilized the population I don't
see any reason that we can't do that
it's worth noting just by way of
specific example right when the Japanese
bombed Pearl Harbor and it was clear now
that we were going to have to get into
the Second World War President Roosevelt
called a bunch of industrial leaders
into the White House and said you know
what are we what can you do when it
comes to producing bombers and tanks and
other kinds of war materiel what are we
producing now and and and and is this is
the following goal a realizable goal the
goal that he put before them was
something like ten times what we were
then producing and they said well we
might be able to double present
production or we might be able to triple
but but ten times that's just not
possible and he said let's make it
eleven and they did it they did it quite
straightforwardly right because they
were serious about it and one of the
things that we're trying to argue here
is that the climate change problem on
the one hand and the continued
degradation of the nation's
infrastructure and manufacturing base on
the other hand are in a sense the moral
equivalent of war right they're just as
important indeed in many ways they're
even more important because there are
much more I think immediate existential
threat to the continental United States
even than the japanese threat was after
the bombing of Pearl Harbor one of the
more practical questions you mentioned
it makes sense to start with what
Democrats and Republicans could agree
upon doing and I completely agree with
you on that my concern is I also agree
with you that something related to
infrastructure is probably that thing
the problem I see with it is that every
proposal for
spending from the current president has
been a crony capitalists handout to his
buddies effectively so I guess from a
practical perspective when the
Republicans continued to control the
Senate and the White House is the only
thing that could happen
a infrastructure an infrastructure plan
that is one of those crony capitalist
handouts and if not how do you get
around it and get Republicans to support
it yeah so I think that the easiest way
to get around this is just to say look
here is a realistic infrastructure
proposal yeah
you drop ran on infrastructure you claim
that it mattered to you and that it was
important to you we're not willing to
turn this into some kind of a crony
capitalist boon simply for your
pocketbook
you've got enough emoluments already
coming from the various other violations
of the emoluments clause that you're
engaged and we're not willing to do it
with infrastructure so here are your
options right infrastructure without
Kearney ISM or no infrastructure my
guess is that Republicans in Congress
and ultimately mr. Trump himself
probably don't want to be characterized
about by the media as the people who
turned down any kind of infrastructural
reform or revitalization simply because
they couldn't personally profit from it
you know I'm not sure about that because
look at what's happened with the wall
right I mean Mexico was going to pay for
it and it was going to fill the entire
us-mexico border - I I guess my might my
thought is it doesn't seem that the
Trump base is going to hold him
accountable for failing to do any of the
things that he promised so I almost
wonder if he would just turn it down if
it's not infrastructure the way he wants
to do it so you might be right David
that the his base might not I mean his
Bay seem to be almost like religious
converts or something such that they'll
come up with some way to explain away
nearly any wrong that he commits but I
think the one thing where we tend to
overlook these days and it's I can
understand why because it's sort of an
unpleasant thought that this might even
be true but sizeable numbers of people
who would have voted for Bernie Sanders
had he been the Democratic nominee voted
for Trump right there is in other words
a swing vote here
that what but what I've seen is that a
statistically insignificant number of
Burnie primary supporters ultimately
voted for Trump where were you getting
that yeah so most of the data that I've
heard about or read about is it's much
more than a statistically insignificant
number of people particularly if you
think in terms of those who also simply
refrained from voting rather than voting
for drop okay so there but that's a
different assertion it is but but again
the point is if you can mobilize large
numbers of people who did not vote
against Trump because they were troubled
about Clinton's being the nominee if you
can mobilize those folks including the
Bernie supporters to you know get out
there and say look yeah we're definitely
gonna get active again and then active
in a very anti trumpian way if we have
to sacrifice infrastructure or
revitalization just because the
president wouldn't allow it to be done
unless he could personally profit from
it my guess is that that's a pretty
effective pitch and even the die-hard
base of Trump supporters do not
constitute anything even remotely
resembling a majority of voters in this
country I hope that you're right and we
will be paying attention to it very very
closely we've been speaking with
Professor Robert Hockett who is a
professor of law and finance at Cornell
University advisor to Alexandria
Castillo Cortes one of the architects of
the green New Deal proposal Robert
really a pleasure having you on today
thanks so much David great to be on with
you